[Musik]
großer andrang in der kaserne in
zwölfaxing niederösterreich grund dafür
ein festakt zur übergabe der neuen
fahrzeuge dingo 2 a 3 durch
bundesminister mario kunasek an die
dritte jägerbrigade wir haben also schon
erfahrung für das sega und 33 mit diesem
fahrzeug dingo noch in der
vorgängerversion
wir werden auf diesem wissen aufbauen
und wir werden also die systeme
implementieren
trotzdem gibt es natürlich noch viel zu
tun ein waffensystem haben mit zu tage
braucht einige jahre 57 jahre bis es
wirklich den standard erreicht dass es
wirklich voll betrieben werden kann
es war eine arbeitsreiche jahre forschte
und die einsatztauglichkeit der neuen
dingo 2 a 3 fahrzeuge wird bei einer
dynamischen vorführung gleich unter
beweis gestellt die modernisierung der
harrah's ausrüstung ist ein kernanliegen
von verteidigungsminister kunasek dass
die nur schrittweise voran kommt ist
klar
aber jeder schritt zählt derweil noch
viele schritte folgen müssen wir wissen
wir dass wir einen großen
investitionsstau haben noch immer haben
aber heute haben ein guter tag mit der
neuen fahrzeugen die jetzt hinter mir
stehen hier mit dem dingo 2 wo wir
geschützte mobilität sicher stellen für
unsere soldaten auch in robusten
einsätzen zur militärischen
landesverteidigung im in aber auch im
ausland
und ich glaube dass dieses gerät ein
meilenstein auch ist da in der
weiterentwicklung auch des oestricher
bundesheeres einer von vielen schritten
die wir noch brauchen
schritt für schritt wird also
modernisiert und mit jedem schritt
wächst auch er wieder der stolz auf die
truppe der sehr groß wir brauchen diese
fahrzeuge es ist ein sehr zeitgemäßes
fahrzeug ist es ein fahrzeug das auch in
anderen armeen verwendung findet und wir
freuen uns dass wir dieses fahrzeug
bekommen die fahrzeugflotte wird auf
insgesamt 99 fahrzeuge aufgestockt mit
einem beschaffungsvolumen von rund 76
millionen
[Musik]